hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Hector now this is
actually a good horror game and there's
a lot of stuff to explore but I'm not in
the same place that I was before also I
need to flick my lighter and get out of
here so I don't exactly know a lot of
what's going on other than the deuce is
a mental hospital ooh please tell me
that's just a fan right okay this is a
fan what does a fan look like a person
why does everything look so horrible
okay so obviously this game is randomly
generated and that means a lot of things
that are comparable to other things but
what it does also mean is that I'm not
gonna be able to navigate around here
wait that door didn't open on the push
but it did open on the poll does that
mean there's been some other doors that
I haven't been able to open just because
I've been an idiot about it probably but
then again I'm an idiot about a lot of
things and that doesn't stop me before
and for some reason the doors seem to be
cooperating a little better than before
pardon domi making strange noises that
is definitely locked and I don't know
why my screen just went wiggly wobbly
I'm guessing oh it's it's because the
game changed on me is so like vanishing
that it just decides to change random
intervals okay so now what the hell is
this have I been here before I think
I've been it alone is that god damn it
I'm sure they set things up to look like
I thought that was a skeleton leaning
out of Locker there I'm willing about
that they set things up intentionally
look like humanoid figures or maybe not
maybe this is luck so that oh okay I
must have been missing a lot of doors
just because I didn't push
yeah I know stop the fire start the
water whatever I don't know the hell was
that oh no whoa the lights actually
worked okay so now this is a new area
that I haven't been before I imagine
it's gonna happen a lot when I progress
through this game but hey my
expectations are very very high low I
guess so did this get me anywhere that I
needed to go no because it's blocked off
and I definitely don't have the strength
to move this giant thing so I guess I'll
just backtrack a bit into the area that
has probably changed since I was last
here all right kill killer run cuz
apparently those eyes that I saw I I
thought I saw in the first part people
pointed out that it might have just been
a speck of dust so that was the first
time that I've been frightened by a
speck of dust which I think reaches a
new low and the amount of things that
I've been scared by which include things
like oh thank you very much why did that
light a light out here
oh this place stopped falling apart I
got places to go okay don't some changed
either that or a shadow has befallen me
any shadows want to follow me up here
I'll punch you in the dick
whoa god damn if he do that
intentionally thing then the darkness
just don't look good friendly okay so
this is the place that I've been to many
many many times school Oh know what it
means
it is definitely not opening okay so now
I have 200 I need some benzo I have I do
not have any pens oh I don't know what
this is supposed to be well I did not
put a gamepad in oh no no I need that
thank you okay so if I can't go through
here I can't go through this door I
never told them what that I hate them
cuz I do
I hate anybody that puts me in one of
these situations where I'm not in
control of my life oh is this where I'm
sure about to start hallucinating
because my vision is starting to go
wiggly wobbly I don't much care for when
my vision goes wibbly-wobbly okay so I
came through there I do not think oh
that was just blocked why was the point
of that being blocked up there wasn't
even a special item I could have gotten
this doesn't make any sense at all but
then again maybe that's a good thing
because it's a mystery that needs to be
solved and then we're gonna be able to
go around and round and around and I was
in the middle of saying something lady
then we're gonna go round and around and
around and get lost forever and chase
these voices that are trying to tell me
things it's probably bad that voices are
talking to me in my head okay push and
pull both locked Hey okay you're gone
push and pull both locked okay so this
is where the surveillance tapes were
wait did I not save Court no oh I did
this I so did that and I know someone in
the comics is like dude you do you there
one thing into those like yes that was
exactly what I was pointing out there's
someone standing in that particular one
right there right there you see that a
person and also the music got a little
bit more dramatic what that means I do
not know
probably means I'm about to die dami you
again okay so that's what happened I was
just wandering around to what I've done
before so now I'm in the new area I need
to find out how to lock the door to go
to cellblock
- okay so this is a generator room that
didn't have anything to do with what I
was doing here or at least I couldn't
figure out how to do it kind of looped a
bit wasted my time
hey that's what I do give to you yah huh
I said you pity you yah not jump-scare
me
that wasn't even jump-scare worthy those
is a creek but I'm a little jumpy you
want to play this game cuz god damn it's
got the atmosphere game is definitely
okay so this just looked around where I
was before it's all changed why the
strings why the strings oh come on I
just went through here maybe I didn't
did that's an awfully dramatic music for
a whole lot of nothin happenin I'm just
under these something that there is a
whole lot of nothin happenin good much
gear for this okay damn I need some pens
Oh bad I need it real bad but I don't
know where to find pills like I'm
assuming they're strewn about the
environment who was that always like
that I don't know I don't care only way
I can goes forward
oh that's right I went down the stairs
oh why have I forgotten all that I've
done
god dammit get looped again back to the
service that's what happened I went to
the surveillance room cuz he loop
there's nothing here
have I read these before I don't know if
I've read these before I haven't seen
Jackson for three days did he go home
probably not
yeah I can't read that one yeah okay I
think I read these food again the music
rather dramatic for a whole lot of
nothing going on so I'm under the
assumption that this is gonna continue
to be a whole lot of nothing going on
well I can live about my daily life I've
been here before
goddamnit I mean it's kind of
disorienting with all the the changing
of the areas just don't do it yeah don't
do that while you do that oh don't do
that
Dell don't do that don't like it when
you do that can I just get some benzo
please I need pills in my mouth I need a
whole lot of pills in my body I'm a bit
of a junkie but I need pills I don't
like this at all like this one bit
you guys keep an eye out for me oh god
dad wasn't living again how about coming
to the same damn place over and over
again
Eve I'm supposed to look I'm breathing
heavy now oh hey I didn't know that was
a known it wasn't glowy how was I
supposed to know house knew that car
missing the tab who signed the petition
I've gone missing we are being
mistreated in this hospital we demand
better treatment you look young yeah I'm
sure that's how well I'm sure that
turned out great for all y'all I need I
need benzo I need benzo I need benzo in
my mouth
Enzo's not a person so don't take that
the wrong way I'm just gonna keep going
till I find my way
again Orchestra
you need to calm your tits cuz I'm not
in the point where things are getting
all strange I mean I am stop that
oh god damn it again with the
loop-de-loops oh good thank you light
that's perfect for me how about some
pills
I need spells I'm gonna get Louis need
pills now you wouldn't share anyway
didn't dumb
god I'm just I don't know if I'm
supposed to do something if I'm just
gonna close to keep moving forward what
does it all mean why am I here is that
how do I get back to surveillance again
son of a [ __ ]
look am I supposed to do something cuz I
am clearly losing my mind here
it's always an interesting case study
when I'm able to literally tell when my
character is losing about his mind
because it coincides with my own job
doors there's a fire stopped or turn
fire shut up right now same place up end
before everyone's getting all sing-songy
well this is exactly the same place I
just went up okay this is just this is
literally sticking with me
oh is that oh that was this a drip drop
of water oh yeah oh this one to equip
flashlight hell yeah oh that is so much
better
no I'm gonna do both I like both it
seems like I have unlimited fuel but I
better have a not unlimited battery was
that was I supposed to find was I
supposed to find that I hope so cuz
otherwise I'm still gonna be wandering
for a while I imagine I'm still gonna be
wandering for a long while because this
game just wants me to wander but at
least I'm gonna be going in a direction
that's gonna be it
hello this is all the scratched up doors
at the same Iskra oh that's what the
security cameras looking at oh why
didn't know that oh well I'm a ding dong
er I wasn't paying attention to the
details that's my bad
but at least I found another collectible
can of zoop me loving me can of soup
okay any bends on here because I need it
badly I don't know oh all this now where
I'm supposed to be okay like that they
have the random showers very useful for
cleansing okay things are starting to
get very Wibbly
I don't know if there's gonna be
anything useful here I get it yes stop
the water start the fire stop the water
start the fire stop the water start the
fire oh this is bright and beautiful
what it's got a turn horrible I'm not
doing well I need my Benz oh why did it
turn red and so so badly oh this is
wibbly-wobbly
oh this Wibbly is all he'll have I seen
some and I just didn't notice it I need
to do is on yellow stand out of
bathrooms no let's go that won't
I wish I could but unfortunately I'm a
little preoccupied with my own life
goddamnit up back here again it's got to
be some pills here give me some damn
pills put pills in my mouth please I'm
begging you please pills in my mouth oh
god am i back here again what does this
mean how do I do this
my flashlights failing did I see I see a
flicker you need pills why ever not been
able to find pills and so long it's
harder to look classic oh that's why I
have the batteries oh okay that makes so
much sense
well I mean it doesn't make so much
got-damn and I'm here again geez what am
I supposed to do oh did I get that
wouldn't when the hell did I get that
what am i had that how long have I had
that I've tried that so many times
before I don't know when I got that oh
oh you're not eyeballs oh looks like bad
was it real
that wasn't real was it ah pills of
transact of pals
oh now you're telling me I need to find
pills well those men my primary
objective for a while now where you
threw something at me cuz we gotta have
pals someone give me my pills I'm an old
man those are not eyeballs oh I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die the snow is falling
into oh hey well okay this is weird I'm
like an epileptic squid on LSD Aryan
okay I'm dead
why am i dead did my head explode I have
a particular feeling that my head
exploded oh no I'm alive Cray lied to
live another day and a pile of snow I
don't want to know I'm gonna assume snow
but this looks nice am I in a circus
oh yes another maze please deliver me
from evil where I walk in the valley of
the shadow of red edgerton's everywhere
red red red whoa why young man in my
film
there is no need for panic no fear
early desire for tomorrow's step into
paradise
ah mr. sessions if this is your
defection never differentiated emptiness
below if this is your definition of
paradise and I don't think velvet arms
is uh we had described bees that's
someone like [ __ ] okay I got your chest
piece that's good for me right I did
I've done good play the game I don't
want to play the game I'm bad at chess
I can barely beat a monkey Oh Naoto
takes it
I don't want to pay your game you rogue
wanna play my own game I want to go home
I want to play the go home game
definitely not know
I see how you is there a gas leak what
is with that sound that's blocked ah
oh that looks warm and inviting I'll go
this way ray I don't have my flashlight
anymore do I know what I do not really
do need some Oh start the water stop the
fire the sprinklers hello I did it I got
a note new picture red oh I gotta read
this one there's me if you were reading
this note it means I wasn't able to come
back force my supplies and you found
them instead means I failed to escape
I'm not sure exactly what's going on in
this place but I found out today my
sessions are starting tomorrow I'm so
afraid I saw what happened to the others
I stole these supplies a flashlight some
food and the key Cardiff oh it was in
the van I didn't even know a keycard was
among that key leads to the cell blocks
that's where their toy it's taking me
please help me find me well this wasn't
even close to where I want oh I got
another one oh if I had read the note I
didn't realize a know came with it ah
that's my ignorance that's my problem
okay Tony smokes and gifts lighter and a
teddy bear retain this copy for your
records alrighty then that's good and
all but um why did I oh oh you've
blocked me in you bastard you bastard
I'm back in the red velvet arms yeah
taco what the [ __ ]
excuse me Jesus Christmas you can't just
do that to a guy
oh hey is that a thing I might have been
a thing I need pills what is with that
oh is that just water or something I
can't pick up the spoon because there
isn't as big let me out I'm not crazy I
swear
give me some food
no I don't know okay so obviously these
are the concrete paddles that I've
smashed my head against a few times can
I get out please plays plays plays
pretty pleased place my world seems to
be warping and it has been for some time
if I could just get out I don't know if
this is not opening or if it's actually
very much okay it's very much locked I'm
just gonna lose the pool
right or left shoes is that what you
said why don't know I can't do anything
again doesn't make any sense what do I
do
hey I'm gonna Ram my face into it I
didn't do anything what did I do
oh boy I'll have this I didn't know I
had this oh I didn't know I had this
either I'll try to choose but it's kind
of hard when I don't know what I'm doing
you know what I mean right or left juice
juice what does it mean
oh there we go okay right or left choose
well left is out of the question so I
guess I gotta go right this turn it up
there we go now I can see I once was
blind but now I see
okay slides one of the sliding doors
pills please good golly I need them so
badly uh which one to take pills
yeah I got a pill now if I get to stop
spasming dad be great can I please not
have this all happening to pills
still Wibbly still very Wibbly is this
gonna settle down
it's another pill down all right I'm
taking enough pills I took so many pills
maybe he's just been so long since I had
one I had to take four pills oh it's
still Wibbly get it that it's Wibbly but
why massage okay goodbye
are you real you're not real are you
you're just a figment of my imagination
because I didn't take my pills I did
take my pills I took a lot of pills yeah
man
damn it all the hell those pills are
here we have tails brush them up and let
me snore them yeah I want more pills
I'm like what's-his-face Tetsuo
from Akira think alack the pills
a love why is this still a thing I'm
trying to take my pills I'm taking a lot
of pills here doesn't seem to be work I
don't know why that interface is messing
up between the controller in the Oh cuz
I don't think I'm a controller attached
maybe I'm not wrong but this this door
didn't seem like it was not locked I
mean my vision is getting a little
better I don't know why I needed to take
so many pills to do it okay
that's locked god it's still Wibbly okay
it's getting a little more normal
I had to take so many pills to do that
it's been so long since I found him oh
hey I had locked of a demon what does
that mean why was he just standing there
alright then we're just gonna act like
that never happened apparently
I don't know what's happening why am i
back in the generator area what's going
on now and again my vision is wobbly why
why must it be this way another note st.
Patrick's Day was yesterday
Patrick's Day was yesterday stole a sip
from the cabinet in Dogs office good
Irish whiskey and the throat and
reminded me of Dublin Dublin I get
irritated doc never asked me to play
chess just the new blood even gave him a
gold watch and told me to leave him
alone huh
wait a minute I have a gold watch don't
I I have a gold watch why do I have a
gold watch that was mentioned before but
either way I'm all out of time for this
episode Simon and this one here pick
this right back up so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always see
I guess this would progress deeper into
the building
make all my troubles go away